Okay. Um, we, this is the
sh the slides from the,
and last time we didn't quite finish it.
Equilibrium versus residence.
Remember equilibrium is a case where
you have two different species,
different structures and they you go
back and forth between them maybe fast,
maybe slow.
Okay.
Like the hydrogen could be attached to
the top or it could be attached to the
bottom I oxygen and those are different.
Two different what's called isomers.
We'll get to that later on.
Or You could imagine the same
thing if you take the hydrogen off,
you could have a short double bond
oxygen and along single bond oxygen.
Or they could exchange as to which
oxygen was long and which was short.
So you could have an equilibrium there,
but it turns out you don't write that.
In fact,
it's not two different species,
right? It's one species.
It's a single minimum, not a
double minimum. Right. Now,
how do you know this?
How do you know it's just one nuclear
geometry with an intermediate bond
distance?
The only way you know is by experiment
or by some really fancy calculation that
you have to believe.
A lot of people would believe
experiments before calculations,
some or the other way around.
Okay.
But there's evidence from a technique
called Electron paramagnetic resonance or
Epr that shows that indeed this
is one species of single minimum,
right? Well, if you have
an extra electron on it,
then you have the carboxylase an ion.
Then again,
it's just one species,
a single minimum. Right?
And there's evidence from that
from infrared spectroscopy
that we'll talk about
next time next semester.
Okay.
But don't be disappointed that
you're not able to predict this.
A lot of really smart,
experienced people couldn't predict it.
Right?
This is lore.
If you look it up in the
Oxford English dictionary,
it says that lore is that which is
learned learning Scottish scholarship area
edition. Also in recent use applied
to the body of traditional facts,
anecdotes,
or beliefs relating to some
particular substance subject.
So a lot of things are Lori,
just have to learn them, right?
You can't predict them ahead of time.
There are way too subtle, right?
So don't be disappointed because
you haven't had enough time yet to,
to get the law. You're not
supposed to know it yet. Right.
It would be nice if Lewis theory was so
accurate and straight forward that if
you could draw two structures,
there are two structures and it's a double
minimum. Right, but that's not true.
Right, and you have to know from something
and you don't have time to know yet.
As time goes on, maybe you'll
figure it out. This is a,
from a good textbook. It might be the
one that will adopt next semester. It's,
it's a quote that says empirical rules.
It's going to give empirical rules for
assessing the relative importance of the
resonance structures,
molecules and ions.
That is if you have two different
pictures that you can draw for the thing,
does it look halfway in between them?
Almost all like one,
almost all like the other or some
fraction of the way between them. How?
How far is it one way or the other?
Right.
These are two different pictures you
draw to try to show different aspects of
the same thing,
but there is one real thing.
The molecule doesn't know about resonance.
Right. It just knows what it is.
The problem is with our notation.
Okay? But anyhow, here's what they say.
So rules that will allow you to use this
concept more productively by deciding
which ones are better, which look
more like the real thing. Okay?
So it gives rules and that number's them.
One resonance structures involved.
No change in the positions of nuclei.
Only electron distribution is involved.
That is when you draw these two
structures, you don't move the Adams,
you just change where you draw a single
bond or a double bond or a dotted bond
or something like that,
right? And in fact,
that's not even true because it's not
the electrons know where they want to be,
right? It's the way we draw
them. That's uncertain, right?
So when you draw two different resonance
structures, you're not changing.
Where are the electrons? Are
you just changing the lines
you draw? Is that clear?
It's our notation that's
at fault. Okay? Number two,
structures in which all first row
Adams have filled octets are generally
important. However,
resulting formal charges.
We talked last time about how
you get formal charges, right?
And electronegativity differences.
And of course we have to know
what electronegativity is,
but you've heard about it at least can
make appropriate non octet structures.
Comparably important
to have a bad charge distribution.
Even though you have octets,
it still might not be a very good
structure. Okay. Number three,
the more important structures are those
involving a minimum of charge separation.
So you don't want to have
formal charge separation,
particularly among atoms of comparable
electronegativity structures with
negative charge is assigned
to electronegative atoms
may also be important.
So if you're going to get a charge,
put it where it wants to be right now,
look at this more
carefully. Uh, number two,
it says generally import.
It doesn't say always important,
but generally,
right?
That's not such a great rule because you
have to know when there's going to be
an exception, okay. Or however,
right? This doesn't
sound like the, the uh,
10 commandments graven in stone.
Right?
Or can make an APP thing that,
not that it will,
but it can or particularly
or may also be important.
These are all weasel words
because the rules or not rules,
right? And at the time, this is all
lore again, so people write these rules,
but really the people who are writing
the rules know the answers ahead of time.
And thank God you generally works that
way. And mostly we can get away with it,
but these are not rules like the rules
you want to learn in physics. I mean you,
you want to learn these because it's, it's
sort of handy, but don't believe them.
Okay. And notice at the top
that it's empirical rules.
It's not a fundamental theory.
These are just ways of sort of correlating
a bunch of the lore that's come in,
right? And what's important is the
experiment's not theories like this.
They will get better theories later.
Okay.
So the goal of this Louis stuff was
from the number of valence electrons.
It would be nice to be able to predict
the constitution that is the valence
numbers for the different atoms.
How many atoms of one kind or another
get together to make a molecule, uh,
that reactivity.
And we've seen a little bit of that.
At least that unshared pairs
can get together with Vaco
doorbells and make a new
bond. That wasn't something that was part
of the original rules of valence, right?
And maybe something about
charge distribution as well.
Now let's look at the case of o two and
o three and apply some of this stuff.
So o two you can have complete the octets
by bringing two oxygen atoms together,
forming two bonds between them.
So that looks pretty good and it's a
double bond and we can draw it that way
with just lines and forget
that unshared pairs,
if we're not particularly concerned
with them at a given time. Okay.
Now suppose you make oh three you could
do the same kind of trick there and make
a three membered ring,
or you could make it linear
or bent instead of a of a
symmetrical three membered
ring. So you got to have an
equal lateral triangle like that.
Or You could have it like this,
have o two and bring in another
oxygen on one of the lone pairs.
Right now,
that's not an equal lateral triangle.
It's a triangle of some sort or could,
could conceivably be a straight line.
We're not quite sure what the
geometric implications are. Okay.
But we could call it an open structure
as a pair as compared to the ring
structure.
Okay.
And we could draw it like that and
the formal charges would be as shown.
Why?
Because that pair that originally belonged
only to the original top oxygen of o
two is now shared with the other oxygen.
So it one of them loses
half interest in a pair.
The other gains have interest in
the parent that's plus minus. Okay.
So the try Vaillant oxygen as positive
as you would expect right now,
what is the true structure of that
molecule? Ozone o three? Well,
you have to do some experiment
to find that out or some uh,
high faluting calculation that you
believe a quantum mechanical calculations.
So it could be a ring or it could be an
open and notice in the open structure
you should have two resonance structures
because you could draw it that way.
Or You could draw it that way.
And it could be two minimum.
It could be a double minima double minimum
situation where it could be distorted
one way or the other and
click back and forth.
Or it could be that the tooth structure
is in the true structure is in between
with equal bond distances, right? So we
have to find out something about this.
Now, one way of finding
that out is to, uh,
is to do calculations and draw a
graph that shows what the answer is.
And that's what we're going to do here.
It's based on some fairly
recent high level calculations,
but the problem is drawing the graph
because if you want to be able to
show the structure you have to, to,
to how many variables do you have to
specify to say what the structure of o
three is,
how many numbers would you have to have?
It's a trial. It's three particles, right?
So if you gave this distance and
this distance and this distance,
that would fix the triangle.
Or You could give this distance and
this distance and the angle here,
that would also specify the triangle.
Okay. But at any way you slice it,
you have to have three numbers to tell
the structure and then you have have to
have another number in your graph to
say what the energy is when it has that
structure.
Okay?
So you have to plot four variables and
that's not trivial on a piece of paper to
plot a graph with four variables in it,
okay?
So three distances plus energy or two
distances in an angle and energy you need
to plot.
So if you're good at plotting things
that have had a lot of experience, great.
But if you need a little warm up exercise,
you could look at this webpage that you
get get by clicking up at the top there,
right?
And it uses these graphs to give you a
little exercise in plotting things that
are in many dimensions day.
But we're not going to do that in class.
That's just to do on your own or
with the discussion section, okay?
And we'll show the specific example of
how we're going to do it in the case of o
three so ti does specify oh
three we need four dimensions.
Now here we have a plot
that shows one distance,
the second distance and
the angle, okay, that's,
that'll specify where the
three oxygens are. But uh,
Rutenberg and his coworkers here in 1997,
when they did the fancy calculation,
uh, did it a little differently.
They constrained it,
they didn't allow everything to vary.
They said we're going to require
the two distances to be the same,
right?
So now instead of three variables,
you have only two and you
can block those two, uh, on,
on a two dimensional paper,
you can plot two things. Okay?
So here's here,
we're going to plot the position
of if you know where that,
if the two distances are equal,
right?
Then if you know the
position at the top right,
you know the position at the top left
because the original oxygen is at the
origin zero, zero.
Everybody with me on that?
So we're going to look only at where the
top right oxygen is and the other one
will be someplace symmetrically
related to it. Okay?
So we're going to blow that up and
here's the plot they give them now. So,
so now any point on this,
we'll specify a precise
geometry of the three oxygens.
Everybody with me, we choose a point
that tells where the top right one is.
The bottom one is at zero zero and the
top left is just on the other side and
the corresponding mirror image position.
So any point on that thing
will specify the structure,
but we now have we still that,
but that's used up our two dimensions
of the paper. How do we show the energy?
Can you think of a three
dimensional graph you've ever used?
Pardon me?
You could color code it. You could make
red really high and blue, really low.
That would be one way to do it.
There.
There are earlier ways
before printing made it,
our computers made it easy to make
colors. Did you ever go hiking? Have Hud
contour lines like like a
geological map? Right. Okay.
So we can draw contour
lines that show where the,
what the energy is for every one of
these geometries. And so at that,
notice that at that position that x,
it turns out to be what would the red
structure would be here, which is a ring.
Okay. Equal. Lateral. Okay.
And this structure is open.
Okay.
And I chose those particular ones because
when you do the fancy calculation,
those turn out to be the ones
that are at the bottom of valleys.
Low Energy, okay. And if
you distort away from those,
the energy goes up.
Now you can go up any direction.
You go from one of the bottoms of
the valleys, you go up in energy,
but there's some particularly
interesting positions.
A particularly interesting position
is that one cause that's the past that
that's the lowest you can go.
The lowest energy that's required
to go from one valley to the other.
Everybody I think has probably done enough
hiking to realize that that's the way
you'd like to hike or that if you were,
if you spilled a cup of water up at
the past, it would run down both ways.
Okay. Now, in fact,
we can use that concept to make it even
a simpler graph where we don't need to
draw contour lines because we could
take the steepest descent path.
Okay.
If you pour the water out at the pass
and follow how it will trickle down,
it'll take the steepest way to go down.
It turns out it crosses
every tour perpendicularly.
Okay, so you follow that and
that would go down to the bottom.
And then if you kept going,
like if you dropped a marble or something
and it rolled down to the bottom,
it would keep going. So there is
a particularly interesting path.
Not that the true molecule would
necessarily have to follow that path,
but it's a well defined path that
gets from one valley to the other.
So now what you could do is take a knife
and slice this thing along that Green
Line and unfolded so it's flat.
Does everybody see how that would be like?
I remember once we took a,
when I was young,
we took a family vacation and the AAA
sent you a map that showed you know where
you would go. But it also
showed the, along the, you know,
along a particular highway and it also
showed another map that showed how high
you were all the time as you went
along the roads. Got The idea.
So this is exactly that kind of thing
where as you go along that green road,
there are different altitudes. So we
could just, we could draw it this way.
Does everyone see how that works?
So it's not quite as specific about
geometry anymore the way the previous one
was, but it shows how, how much
energy you need as you go along.
Okay.
And a particularly important one,
there are two things that
are really important.
One is how high much one valley
is compared to the other,
how much more stable one is. And the
other is how much higher is the past?
How hard is it to get from one to
the other? Okay. So that's uh, so,
so there are now is in a two
dimensional graph that you can draw on.
A piece of paper is something that
gives you this information. Okay.
Uh,
but this required that we choose our one
two equals r two three in order to make
this simplification, right. It, the
guys who did the calculations said,
if we don't make our one
two equal to r two, three,
then it turns out that all the
structures are still higher in energy.
So these are the lowest energy structures,
right?
Although they can't plot them
on a piece of paper. Okay. So,
uh,
so the lowest energy structure is this
open form and it does have our one to
equal our two three. It's a
resonance structure halfway between,
not one double bond in one single bond,
but a symmetrical one.
Okay. So it's a symmetrical single
minimum found by calculation and there's
experimental evidence that supports
that too, but it's more complicated.
Now how about the charge distribution?
What would the Lewis structures that
we've drawn here predict about charge
separate, uh, separation?
Would there be charged any place do you
think on the basis of this and the real
molecule, which is symmetrical, what
do you think? Anybody got a suggestion?
Yeah.
Oxygen.
Regardless of which to
structure that time. Yeah.
Both structures have it
positive in the middle.
So that looks like a good
prediction, right? And then, uh,
partially negative and equally negative
on the two ends. Now is that true?
Well, here's a picture that
the based again on Quan.
So the prediction is positive in the
middle, negative on the ends. Is it true?
Well, there's the truth.
There's the structure,
the minimum energy according
to calculation, right?
Quantum mechanical calculation.
And we can draw what's called the
surface potential of that structure,
which again comes from calculation.
So you put a proton,
you define the molecular surface and
that is a little bit of a problem,
but we'll talk about that later
where the molecular surfaces,
but then you put a proton at a point
on it. And we talked about this before.
And for ammonium chloride you put
a proton on and you find, or no,
it was the, the uh, uh, Bnh six we
talked about the surface potential.
Here's the same thing for o three,
and you'll notice the surface
potential is high in the middle,
a bad place to put a proton
because there's positive
charge there and it's low.
On the two ends at least
someplace on the two ends. Right.
So more or less that Lewis
structure predicted this. Right.
So that's great. Okay. We're not
confident that we'll always work,
but maybe the law will build
up that way. Okay. And it does.
Okay,
so charge distribution also.
So reactivity we saw was a special
attribute of this nice Lewis Theory and
charge distribution at
least qualitatively,
if not in detail for o three
and also for the Bnh six.
Now how about specific
distances and specific angles?
We'll get into that later on as to whether
you can do that from something like a
Lewis structure.
And how about the energy content?
Wow,
that's not so good actually
for with just Lewis structures,
but we'll test it later. Okay,
so the Lewis dot structures,
it attempts to provide a physical
basis for the valence rules based on
completing octets and
sharing electrons for bonds.
What it gives us new is reactivity due
to unshared payers where both of the
hooks in the bond come from the same Adam,
you might say,
and it's convenient for
electron bookkeeping.
It certainly tells you what the
molecular charge is. The uh,
formal atomic charges are qualitatively
realistic as we've just seen,
at least in the case of o three.
And there's this question
of stability and resonance,
but resonance actually is not
something nature knows anything about.
It's just a correction.
We try to apply to having made
drawings based on Lewis Theory.
It's not something serious.
No,
but this leaves us with some serious
questions. Why does Lewis Theory work?
What's so great about octets? Why
not have a different number? Right?
Or if you have assessed tete
instead of an octet, how bad is it
or how bad or structures that have
charged separation had said in those rules
that you don't want to have charge
separation. Well, how bad is it?
Suppose you had a choice.
You either had to have a sextet instead
of an octet or you had to have charge
separation,
which one would win?
Okay.
How bad is bad charge separation?
Remember it said that if
you put the negative charge
on an electronegative atom,
that's not so very bad.
But how bad.
Yeah.
Now, last year in the Wiki, there came
an interesting comment. Somebody said,
I have a question.
When drawing these structures,
is it more important to try to fill
the octet or to have the lowest formal
charge on as many atoms, especially
carbon as possible? And why?
That's a good question because
Lewis doesn't tell you that at all.
Okay. And there's further the
question, is this at all true?
Are there electron?
This is a really important question.
We're going to spend some time on it.
Are there electrons in between the
nuclei that hold them together?
Pairs of electrons.
It'll take us several lectures
to get to answer that question.
Are there electron pairs between
Nuclei and, and, and are,
are there unshared ones on
some atoms? What, what's the
nature of the forest laws?
That's what we're after.
Remember here altogether
now as to whether Lewis theory is right.
There's a very fundamental theorem in
physics that was developed in 1839 by
Samuel earn Shaw, who was a
tutor at Cambridge. Uh, and the,
the statement of the theorem is that in
systems governed by inverse square force
laws, things like gravity, magnetism, uh,
electrical,
electrostatic interaction,
there can be no local minimum
or maximum of potential energy.
He proved it mathematically.
It's not our business to repeat his proof,
but that's the statement of it.
But we want to understand what that means.
That one thing that means is that you,
if you have Coolum bake
interaction positive, negative,
you can't have a minimum energy structure
that has a nucleus here and eight
electrons at the corner of a cube because
they're inverse square force laws.
And that can't be a minimum energy.
If it distorted, it would keep going.
Now can visualize
earn cias there. I'm here in terms of, uh,
electrostatic for electrostatics by the
analogy that you've all seen of magnetic
lines of force. Everybody's seen
something like this, I think, right? Uh,
and the idea, if it's
electrostatic rather than magnetic,
the idea is that lines of force emerge
from a positive charge and converge on a
negative charge.
And then you'd make them continuous
by drawing these lines of force,
which iron filings of
course did in that case.
And this was the idea
of Michael Farah day,
whom we met a little while back and
he thought these lines of force,
we're real physical things,
right?
Most people don't think that now they
think they're just graphs of that involve
inverse square forced laws.
But he thought they were real.
And the neat thing about them is they
not only show the direction of the force
that upon that,
uh,
charged body would feel because
of the other charge body,
the one that created the lines of force,
they not only show the force,
but they show the direction of the forest.
They all show should also
show how strong the force is.
And the strength of the force
is by the density of lines,
the denser the lines,
the stronger the force.
Everybody's familiar with this idea.
Okay,
speak up if things are not
familiar because I'm assuming
they are. If I say so.
Okay, so you've seen that. Now let's
just think about that a little bit.
Suppose you look at the line density
here through that little line there,
three lines of force that pass.
So let's say that means they're three
for the force is three at that and it's
obviously pointing to the right.
Okay.
Now suppose you check
that out at that distance.
Stronger force or weaker force,
weaker in fact only one or one
and a half or something like that.
Lines of forests are going through that.
Now how does it depend on distance,
the number of lines going through this
standard length line, the blue one?
Well you see that in flat land,
we're just doing this in two dimensions.
We'll get to three in just a second.
In flatland in two dimensions,
the circumference through which
all of these lines of forest pass,
the length of the circumference is
proportional to the radius, right?
So if you go out twice as far,
there's twice the circumference.
So the density of lines passing through
it is half as big. Everybody got that?
Okay,
so that means the forest,
which is proportional to the line density
must be proportional to one over R.
Okay.
So then as you move out twice,
there'll be half as many lines move out
three times a third as many lines. Okay,
but this is just in two dimensions.
Now let's think about how's it going
to be different in three dimensions?
Kaitlin,
speak up a little bit.
I buy or hearing isn't so great.
I said I wanted my 50th
high school reunion. Right?
Set up a line.
It would be more,
yeah, it'd be. It would be
a two dimensional area that
the stuff's going to be.
Now how if you have a certain number
of lines passing through at a certain
distance and you go out twice as far how,
what's the density?
The line's going to be.
Can you think?
Anybody help? Yes.
That'll be inverse square,
inverse square,
because now we're not talking about
the circumference of a circle.
We're talking about the area of
a sphere as we go out, right?
So if we go to three dimensions here
and take your area and move it out,
it's got the surface is going to be
proportional to our square as you go out.
So the line density is going
to be one over r square.
So if you have an
inverse square force law,
then you can draw lines of force.
The lines of force won't work if you
don't have an inverse square forest law
because they have to drop off this
way in order to, uh, in order to give,
uh,
lines of force.
So in three d such diagrams work
only for inverse square forces.
You can't draw thing like
that for a Hooke's law.
Okay?
Right now.
So here's a whole bunch of charges,
positive and negative in the lines
of force between them, right?
And notice something interesting.
The lines of force start
on positive charges and,
and on negative charges,
there's no other place in space where all
the lines go away from it or go toward
it.
Everybody see that it's only at the
charges that they all go away or all go
toward,
right.
And that has a very important
meaning that you can't have, uh,
some place, often free space where all
the lines of force, we're converge.
Notice if you were to have something
that was positively charged, right?
And it's at a minimum of energy
than any place you displace it.
It'll get pushed back, right? If
it's at the lowest point in energy,
you push it any direction
that'll come back.
That is all the lines of force
must converge on that point. Okay.
Everybody with me on that,
but it can't be the only place that
all the lines of force converge is on a
negative charge. It can't be any place
in. If you have inverse square laws,
you can't have some place in space,
which is the lowest energy place for the
charge to be except on another charge.
The same is true of,
you can't have a maximum either.
That's that's a visualization
of Earnshaw is therapy.
So if you have inverse square forest
laws or any combination of inverse square
force laws, like a combination
of gravity and electrostatics,
then magnetic.
You can't get a minimum energy structure
unless everything just falls
together or blows apart. Okay,
so we're gonna chose theorem in systems
governed by inverse square forest laws.
There can be no local maximum or minimum
of potential energy in free space.
Okay. Now. Does everyone do that then?
That's why I don't just float here.
Right. I have to be on the floor.
All right. Did you ever see
anything truly levitating?
Yeah.
Something that just sits in space and
doesn't move, not touching. Anything else
that's been levitated
Ian for 10 or 15 years.
It's not plugged into anything.
It's just this thing right here.
Right.
What do you conclude from seeing that
about the forest laws that are involved?
There must be some force involved in that.
That's not an inverse square force law.
Otherwise it wouldn't work.
Okay. Now it's not our best. If you can
read about it on the web if you want to.
It's not the business of this class.
There is a non inverse square force law
involved in that little magnet sitting
there.
Okay.
Uh, the only stationary points allowed
by Earnshaw is they are immersed saddled
points where you move,
wonder it where it's, it's,
it's flat in energy for all directions,
but you go one direction,
then you go down, you go the
other direction, you go up.
That's like a potato chip or saddle.
So you can have saddled points.
But you can't have absolute
minimum or maximum of energy.
There's the picture of that thing.
Uh, let me, let me do the, uh,
this reminds me to get
back to seeing who's here.
I'll call the people who weren't here
earlier. Anthony Anderson. Uh, that,
where are you? There you go.
Alright. Uh, Maria Baruch Java.
Is it, is that how you say your
name? Bureau? Cova. Okay, good.
Uh,
Sebastian colleary colleary
is that in the Italian name?
Do you know what that
says? You know what? It's,
it's a sort of upon like thing,
you know what Galileo is supposed
to have said after the inquisition
and still it moves a poor war movie,
but this is, and still it
stands there despite or in Shaw.
So there's a little joke
there. Okay. A young Cho.
Okay. Uh, Ryan daily. Yeah. Good.
Uh, let's see. Let's put this here. Uh,
Chris ally saw you come
in, uh, John Greenwald.
Ah,
Gotcha.
Uh,
oh, being a bulk way. How do
you say your name? Okay, good.
Uh,
Serena ire.
No. Ginger Jang? No.
Uh,
Genu Lynn?
No.
Uh,
Ben Leo
here.
Uh,
Maxima.
Kaylee mchaley Macaulay.
Macaulay,
is that originally a Scottish name?
Cutting.
They're, they're Polish names
that are mixed. Some, you
know, like an ice McBride.
I'm interested in it. They're, they're uh,
Catholics from Scotland after
the reformation fled to Poland.
Is there Poland names that are Scottish?
Actually like McCawley McCawley would be
such a thing but it's not. It's Italian.
Okay. Kelly. Thank you. Uh,
Jackie perilla there Ar uh,
Ryan Park.
Gotcha.
Uh, Angela, she is it Shay? She HSA. What
she
okay. Devin Smith. Yeah.
Uh, Naomi Woo. Yeah. Gotcha.
Uh,
South Yang.
Good. And Kevin? John?
Nope. Good. We're getting
there. And Sherry Jo
now, how do you say your last name? Joe.
Joe Zo.
Zo Good.
Right on
Zo.
Okay,
great.
And is there ever been a buddy been
able to sign up for lab that so far?
If not, you can talk to talk to across
the hall after the class. I don't have,
don't send me anything that has to do
with labs cause I'm not involved in it.
Okay, great. Thanks. Now we'll continue.
You've got a few more minutes
here and yet it stands still.
So there's must be something that's not
an inverse square force law there. Okay.
So Jay Jay Thompson in 1897
discovered the electron.
So the idea is maybe electrons have
something to do with bonds. You know,
that's what,
that's what brought Louis into the game.
But Thompson himself came up with what
was came to be called and I don't know by
who first. I've tried to find out
in camp the plum pudding. Adam,
has anyone ever heard of that? Yeah. Okay.
And I suspect that when people told
you about the plum pudding out them,
they sort of snickered. Am I right
that this was sort of a naive idea?
It's not that naive at all. Let me show
you what, here's, here's the book by uh,
by uh, Jj Thomson called the
corpuscular theory of matter.
And if you look in there,
you'll find out what he's talking about.
He says he has a model of
electron configuration. He says,
consider the problem of how to arrange
one, two, three, up to end core puzzles.
That's what he called electrons.
He called them core puzzles.
Consider the problem as to how they
would arrange themselves if placed in a
sphere filled with positive electron,
the positive electricity
of uniform density.
So that's the idea that plum pudding,
you have this,
this sphere of uniform positive density.
Why it should be that that is not,
nobody knows.
But suppose you have a sphere and you
put the electrons in it like plums in a
plum pudding, which is like a
fruitcake and England. Okay. Okay.
Now notice that he said placed in a
sphere filled with positive electricity.
Why did he do that? Why didn't he
just have like Ruth Rutherford all?
We did a nucleus.
Which positive charge in electrons
around them about why did he put the
electrons inside the positive charge?
Zach,
I can't hear very well.
No,
yes,
no, no. They weren't
thinking about things moving.
They want him just sitting there.
Yeah.
Yeah, but that's well known.
Cool. Ohms law. Yeah. Keith.
Kevin,
right?
A
positive spirit.
Yeah, but that, that
could be, if it didn't,
it wouldn't have to be a big
sphere of uniform density.
You could have a little particle of, of,
of positive charge of the same charge.
Right. It'd be the same deal. Yeah.
No, none of this is it. It's what
we've just been talking about. Yeah.
Claire Accounting for the bonding
between the electrons and the protons
contained, no bonding hasn't come up yet.
This is something very fundamental. Yeah.
Pudding.
He probably liked plum pudding at
Christmas. Yeah. Probably hit here.
Did he have experiment?
No.
Yeah.
Ah.
Earnshaw you can't have an energy
minimum for separate particles.
But if you put the negative
ones inside the positive one,
then you can get a stable structure.
It's Earnshaw is there of that
required it to be a plum pudding.
Okay.
Now why a sphere?
Why not a donut or a or some other
shape of barbell or something?
Right.
And he said their district,
that the positive charge is distributed
in a way most amenable to mathematical
calculation. He chose a sphere.
So it would be simple. You know,
if you've heard about spherical
cows and so on like that,
that physicists like to calculate,
let's suppose there's a cow,
let it be a sphere. Right? So that's what
he did. That's why the, it's a sphere.
Okay.
We can solve the special case where the
core puzzles are confined to a plane.
If you could do it in two dimensions,
it's difficult mathematically
in three dimensions,
but you can do it in two dimensions. And
he gives a picture in this book, right?
Like this,
which is a solenoid magnet that attracts
little needles that are magnetized.
And those needles are stuck into corks,
which float in the water,
right?
So they have to,
the corks have to stay at the
level of the surface of the water.
So it's a two dimensional problem.
The needles are parallel to magnets,
so they repel one another, but the big
magnet attracts them to the center.
Okay?
So what he does is toss a certain number
of needles in corks in there and see
what pattern they form.
Okay.
So here are some patterns.
You can get these on the webs
at Greg Blinders website here.
So if you have just one, it goes to the
center. No big deal. If you have to,
you get a line,
there's no big deal about that.
Three make an equal lateral triangle
put in for, they make a square,
put in five. You make a Pentagon. No
one's surprised so far, I suspect,
except that sometimes when you
put in Vive and shake it up,
you get a square with one in the middle.
Can you see where this might be going?
Yeah,
let's keep going. I'll say, okay.
If you put in six you get
one inside of Pentagon,
seven one inside a hexagon,
eight one inside a Hep to God,
nine two inside,
10 to inside.
And sometimes it's like that.
These are experimental,
right?
And if you put 11 it's three
inside and then three inside nine,
although sometimes you get to,
pardon me, I, I'm screwing up here.
Sometimes you get,
there are two different patterns.
Sometimes you get three inside eights
on as you get to inside nine. Okay.
For that number. Okay. And then you
get four inside, nine, four inside,
five inside 10 and then after five,
if you put in more,
if you put in 16
you get one inside five inside
10 what does this remind you of?
Yeah.
The shell structure of atoms,
right? As you go down the periodic
table, you complete a shell.
So it's a model of shells, right? And then
you can get, uh, more and more and more.
Okay. So this is what
Thompson was thinking about,
but that's just two dimensions, right?
Three dimensions is a bigger problem,
but he could say he was able to say
something mathematically about eight.
The equilibrium of eight core puzzles at
the corners of a cube is unstable even
if you have this vertical charge.
So it's not exactly Earnshaw. Still,
you can't get eight at the corners of
a cube. Now, Louis came, comes along,
and in 1923, as I told
you before, he writes,
I have ever since regarded the cubic
octet as representing essentially the
arrangement of electrons in the atom.
This is long after,
uh, Thompson had written this
about not being able to do that.
So was Louis ignorant
of earn Shaw's Theorem?
Because by 1923,
they know that the nucleus
is not a plum pudding. The,
that is the positive
spear that it's a point,
right?
So was Louis just naive?
No.
Look what he wrote in 1916 the electric
forces between particles which are very
close together do not obey the
simple laws of inverse squares,
which holds at greater distances.
So cool ohms law breaks down.
You don't have inverse square,
so then you don't have
earned Shaw's therapy and you
don't have to worry and you
couldn't get a structure if it's
not an inverse square force law,
no trouble. But what is
the forest law? Well,
Thomson thought the same thing in 1923
in his book, the electron on chemistry,
he wrote if electron nuclear attraction,
we're to very strictly
as the inverse square,
we know by Earnshaw is there and that
no stable configuration is possible with
the electrons at rest are oscillating
about positions of equilibrium.
I shall assume that the law of force
between a positive charge and an electron
is expressed by this equation.
Then a number of electrons
can be in equilibrium about
a positive charge without
necessarily describing orbits around it.
And look at the,
we're going to end right now by looking
at this equation. What's that bit of it?
The first bit, the one
part that's cool. Ohms law.
He's got a correction to cool
ohms law here at the end,
c over r where C is a distance,
you divided by r and you get a number
and see as a distance that's on the scale
of atomic lengths, right? And that,
that as long as C is, is, is very small,
uh, per partner as long as, uh, uh, I
said, what if I got this right? Okay.
So when distance are gets smaller than C,
then the force changes sign.
Okay?
So what was attractive becomes repulsive.
And then you can have the electrons
sitting around the nucleus.
Okay?
So we'll see what happened
three years later. Next time.